(soft music)
- [Narrator] When it comes
to electric vehicle manufacturing,
few resources are as vital as lithium.
Over the past decade,
prospectors unearthed troves
of the lithium chemicals
that power batteries,
but the shift toward a cleaner
economy is accelerating
and batteries play a central role.
As a result, demand for lithium
is expected to exceed supply through 2025.
Car makers and analysts say
that more lithium is needed
to produce more batteries
at a faster pace.
And as China takes a leading role
in the battery supply chain,
the US government is trying
to boost domestic supply of the metal.
Here's how Lithium became
such a hot commodity.
Lithium is scattered
not only across the US
but the entire world.
In the top lithium producing
country, Australia,
miners excavate a
mineral called spodumene,
which contains the metal.
And in Chile and Argentina,
companies extract lithium
from massive salt lakes
by pumping water into the ground.
The extracted metals are
mixed with other elements
to produce compounds,
like lithium hydroxide
and lithium carbonate.
These compounds are a key
part of many batteries.
Car makers and battery
researchers, like Dr. Guihua Yu
value Lithium because of its
unique chemical properties.
- With lithium ions being so small,
they can be very easily
recharged, as they diffuse quickly
during battery charge and discharge.
Lithium ions are also very light weight,
so batteries based on Lithium
ions can offer high energy
meaning that a lot of energy can be packed
in a small amount or
small volume of materials.
- [Narrator] These two properties,
energy density and rechargeability
are the reason why lithium is
found in so many batteries.
Inside of all batteries
are two major components,
the cathode and the anode,
compounds that contain lithium ions
transfer from one components
when power is drawn down
and they return when the
battery is recharging
- [Guihau Yu] And they can be charged
like hundreds or thousands of times
so they have different kind
of degradation mechanism.
But lithium ions are so small,
so they are very stable.
So that's the reason why the lithium ions
can offer at least a few years of use.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Scientists have spent decades
perfecting lithium based batteries.
Lithium was discovered in 1817,
but more than a century passed
before businesses used the chemical
in mainstream batteries.
In the 1990s, Sony took advantage
of new, lightweight lithium ion batteries
in a design for a hand-held video camera.
The result was the Handycam.
A smash commercial hit.
Shortly afterward, rechargeable batteries
began to appear in
laptops and smartphones.
And batteries are increasingly used
in conjunction with wind and solar power.
Analysts like Simon Moores point out
that demand for the chemical is growing
as companies build bigger,
battery-powered machines.
- People need more lithium today,
and in the future than in the past,
because you're going from
lithium ion batteries
the size of your mobile phone
to lithium ion batteries
the size of your car.
The entire chasse of an electric vehicle
is a lithium ion battery.
So there's an order of magnitude bigger,
and as a result
you need an order of
magnitude more lithium supply.
- [Narrator] Which means
that mining companies
around the world are
searching for lithium.
In the United States,
companies like Lithium
Americas and Piedmont Lithium
are looking for metal-bearing
spodumene minerals
in familiar places.
In the past,
lithium from the tin-spodumene
belt of the Carolinas
was used in the production
of both medication,
and nuclear weapons.
Today prospectors are fanning out
in search of new deposits here,
as well as in Arkansas,
Nevada, and California.
The search is based on
expectations of consumer demand
for electric vehicles.
- It takes 4 to 7 years
to build a lithium mine,
it takes 24 months to
build a battery plant.
These two parts of the supply chain,
they don't live in the same time zones.
And that is the major challenge,
is matching the supply
when the demand is needed,
and at present, the industry
has really failed to date.
- [Narrator] Even though E.V. sales
currently make up about 2%
of the U.S. auto market,
that share is expected
to grow to 10% by 2025,
according to Morgan Stanley.
And policies coming out of Washington
could further boost demand
for battery components.
President Biden ordered a review
of domestic supply chains
for critical products.
That includes
semiconductors, key minerals,
pharmaceuticals, and,
- Advanced batteries
like the ones used in electric vehicles.
There's strong bipartisan support
for fast reviews of these four areas
because they're essential to
protecting and strengthening
American competitiveness.
- [Narrator] President Biden's emphasis
on supply chain is driven
in part by geopolitics.
When it comes to lithium,
only about 1% of global output
is both mined and processed in the U.S.
China unearths about 10%.
China also processes about two thirds
of the worlds lithium supply,
and dominates the global battery market.
The U.S. government has said
that relying on oversea sources
for these materials creates
a strategic vulnerability,
which means that a new hunt for lithium
is only getting started.
The race is on to see who
will supply the world,
with this powerful metal.
(soft music)